Hello everyone,
welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is the Dutch language
Dutch as a language that's spoken mainly
in Europe,
but also in a few other places around
the world.
It has $23,
million native speakers and around $28
million speakers in total,
including second language speakers.
It is most widely spoken in the
Netherlands where it has around $16
million native speakers.
It has also spoken by around 60 percent
of the population of Belgium,
mostly in the northern region of
Flanders.
That's around six point $5 million
people.
It's also spoken by a small number of
people across the border in French
Flanders,
which lies adjacent to Belgium,
but only around 20,000
people there still speak it on a regular
basis.
It has also spoken in the South American
nation of Suriname where it has around
350,000
native speakers as well as around
$250,000.
Second language speakers.
It is also an official language on the
island of Aruba,
along with the language poppy,
a mental,
but few of the hundred thousand people
that are actually used Dutch even though
they all learn it in school.
It has also spoken in Jira,
so where it is spoken by around 15,000
people as a native language and by many
of the other 140,000
people as a second language.
It is also an official language in Sint
Maarten along with English.
A couple of thousand people there speak
Dutch,
but English is actually much more
common.
There is also Afrikaans language spoken
in South Africa and Namibia,
which is a daughter language of Dutch
and is mutually intelligible to some
extent,
but I'll leave Africans out for now and
I'll speak about it in a different video
in the future.
Dutch as a member of the West dramatic
branch of the dramatic language family,
which also includes Afrikaans,
Friesian,
English and German among others.
Dutch is one of the languages that is
most closely related to English.
Actually,
Phrygian is more closely related to
English,
then Dutches,
but Dutch is a close second and a lot of
people say that Dutch is quite similar
to German too.
In fact,
some people say that Dutch lies
somewhere between English and German.
Now,
that's not a very precise statement,
but I think there is some truth to it.
The history of Dutch,
all dramatic language is developed from
Provo Germanic,
which was spoken around 500 bce in
northern continental Europe and also in
Scandinavia by the second century ce.
It had begun diverging into distinct
northern western and eastern dialects.
The Western dialect is the ancestor of
Dutch and have all of the West Germanic
languages.
Variation developed in the western
dialects,
but all of its varieties remained
intelligible until around the eighth
century CE.
But by then a series of sound changes
had begun to take place that made old
high German,
the ancestor of modern German,
much more distinct from the other
western manic languages.
For more information on German that it's
history,
check out my video on German,
right to hear old Dutch.
Also known as old low Franconian
remained unaffected by the changes that
affected old high German,
also unaffected.
We're old Saxon Bolt,
Friesian and old English,
but those languages underwent a
different series of sound changes,
but again,
Dutch was mostly unaffected by these
changes to middle Dutch,
old Dutch developed into Middle Dutch,
which was spoken and written between
1150 and 1500 cd.
It was a rich literary periods and
literature from this time period is
often quite readable for speakers of
modern Dutch because Dutch is quite a
conservative language.
Middle Dutch developed into modern Dutch
by the middle of the 16th century.
The process of the standardization of
Dutch began in the year 14,
77 at the end of the Middle Dutch
period.
The dialects of flenders and Brad bond
were most influential at that time.
Then in the 16th century,
the move to standardization became
stronger with the end top dialect being
the most influential in the year.
16,
37,
the first major Dutch Bible translation
known as starts in and had been
published.
It hasn't been translated in such a way
that people from all over the country
could read and understand it.
This Bible was read by nearly everyone
and it helped greatly in the
standardization of Dutch,
the southern Netherlands.
Now Belgium and Luxembourg were separate
and under Spanish,
Austrian,
and then French rule.
More than half of the people in Belgium
spoke a dialect of Dutch,
but French was most widely used in
public life in schools,
etc.
So dutch remained unstandardized there
until the 19th century when the flemish
movement started standing up for the
rights of dutch speakers.
They adopted the Same standard language
used in the Netherlands.
NowaDays in both the Netherlands and in
flanders,
the northern dutch speaking region of
Belgium.
The situation is similar.
There are a number of spoken varieties
of dutch as well as a standard language,
so the difference lies mainly in
pronunciation of standard dutch and in
the local dialects used.
The dialects of flenders tend to be more
conservative and use more older dutch
vocabulary.
Regional languages.
There are dutch dialects,
but there are also different regional
languages that are west dramatic
languages and closely related to dutch,
but not as closely related as the
dialects that are considered part of
dutch regional languages in the
Netherlands include friction in the
northern province of friesland,
low saxon and the northeast,
and there are various dialects of low
saxon and lindbergh ish or east low
franconia in the se lo saxon spreads
across the border with Germany and forms
part of a dialect continuum between
dutch and german.
If you've seen my german video,
you know that the dialects in northern
Germany are referred to as low german
and can be considered a separate
language.
The dutch low saxon dialects are closely
related to the low german dialects
across the border.
This is also true for linda borgess,
which is related to franconia and
dialects spoken across the border in
Germany.
It should be noted that dutch dialects
and regional languages are in decline
with standard dutch becoming more
widespread and with some people speaking
a kind of combination of standard dutch
with some dialectal features.
So what is dutch like?
Dutchess,
not mutually intelligible with english,
but you will often notice cognitive
vocabulary and at the most basic level
you will notice similar grammar.
If you disregard the details and just
look at the most basic sentences.
Occasionally there are sentences in
dutch that might be strangely familiar
to english speakers.
For example of this year,
this means,
what is your name?
Man amish to duke.
This means my name is luke to beach,
drunk beach.
This one means the bear drank beer.
I think I must have gotten that one from
duolingo.
This neat fit.
This means it is not far these news.
This means that is good news now at all
dutch sentences were so similar to
english than the two languages could
probably be quite intelligible with each
other,
but most sentences are not that similar
to english,
but you will see a lot of cognitive
vocabulary,
grammar,
similar to german,
dutch as a language that places verbs at
the end of the sentence,
after the first initial group.
So it's underlying structure is
basically sov,
but the first verb is in second position
after the subject.
So if there's only one verb in the
sentence,
then it's basically like svo.
Here's a sentence with one verb him
belief.
This means I am writing a letter word by
word.
This is like I write a letter just like
english with the bourbon second
position.
Here's the sentence with two verbs.
He can fuel you have of liquors cave,
and this means I want to give you some
goodies word by word.
It's I want you indirect object.
Some goodies give in the sentence.
The first verb is in second position,
but the next verb comes at the end of
the sentence.
Nouns,
gender,
when it comes to gender,
dutch traditionally has three genders,
masculine,
feminine and neuter.
But in modern spoken dutch,
the distinction between masculine and
feminine,
gender has almost become irrelevant
because they don't look or sound
different.
It used to determine which pronoun would
be used to refer to those nouns,
whether it's he or she,
but people generally just use he these
days.
So now the two genders are basically
common.
Gender and neuter,
the announced gender agrees with
articles as well as the forms of
adjectives,
plural.
There are two types of neural endings in
dutch,
one is n,
and the other is yes,
there are some,
well not rules but patterns for when to
use each one,
but there are a lot of exceptions,
so you have words like douche dude and
votes bulletin and you have words like
just little doodles,
the labels,
a few neuter nouns have a plural form.
Irwin,
for example,
cases dutch used to have now in cases
similar to german,
there were four cases,
nominative,
genitive,
dative and accusative.
These were part of standard written
dutch until the 19 forties,
but they were dropped because nobody
used them in speech anymore.
There are several different articles in
dutch.
There is an indefinite article and and
there are definite articles for singular
and plural nouns for singular masculine,
the for singular feminine,
the for singular neuter head and the
definite article for plural,
for all genders.
The an interesting thing is there is a
negative article came.
This is the same for all genders and for
both singular and plural verbs.
There are two verb tenses in dutch past
and present or non past,
but saying there are two tenses.
Is kind of misleading because similar to
an english,
the verb can be used in combination with
different auxiliary verbs to express
different meanings,
and there are participle forms that can
be used to show a passive or continuous
action.
For example,
here's a sentence using the simple past
had about this means he built a house.
So we start with the infinitive bowen,
and this is the verb stem,
and this is the past tense form boda.
Now here's a perfect sentence.
Often,
often boats,
this means he has built a house,
so we start with the infinitive heaven
and here's the verb stem,
and here's the past tense,
and the second verb is a past
participle.
This is formed by adding the prefix and
the suffix.
The notice again that the second verb is
at the end of the sentence,
even though the first verb is in second
position after the subject,
there are three different ways to
express the future tense.
One of them is to use this auxiliary
verb.
This means something like shell or will
he had more than this sentence means I
will do it tomorrow.
You can also use this verb meaning to go
plus the infinitive.
This is similar to using going to an
english,
for example,
headscarf and eighth,
and then this means it's going to rain
and you can also use the present tense
for the future xy coleman per slot.
This means they won't come until later.
Literally they come only later,
so the verb system in dutch is rather
similar to the one used in english.
The main difference being that any verb
after the first one comes at the end
pronunciation,
one of the hardest parts of learning
dutch might be the pronunciation because
there are some sounds that can be a
challenge for learners and native
speakers of dutch seem quite conscious
of the challenges we face.
That was kind of an indirect way of
saying they think our pronunciation
sucks.
Some of the sounds that require special
effort are the dutch g sound,
for example,
and the sound which ch often represents.
For example,
notice that this is the same sound as
the one represented by ge,
but in other cases,
ch represents the ship sound.
Now,
sometimes those sounds come at the
beginning of a word,
which is a little bit of a challenge,
but sometimes they come right after the
letter s like in the word for school
skol.
The sound combination is quite common in
dutch.
There are a lot of long words in dutch.
Some of them can be over 30 characters
long.
Here are a couple of extreme examples.
Myhrvold persona,
the kite store,
nice.
This one means multiple personality
disorder and that is 35 characters long
through it,
but adding reading some hayden plum.
This one means preparation activities
for our children's carnival procession
and this is 53 characters long and dutch
also has a lot of colorful idioms,
for example,
mocked up the guts.
This means make the cat wires.
This means that someone is saying
something so outlandish or unbelievable
that even the cat won't believe it.
Another example of houston,
but indicator,
this means he has a beard in his throat.
This idiom describes a situation when a
boy reaches puberty and his voice starts
to change.
How hard is dutch to learn for english
speakers?
A lot of dutch will seem strangely
familiar and of course that will help,
but there are some issues and learning
the pronunciation as well as the finer
details of grammar,
but maybe the hardest thing about
learning dutch is that dutch speakers
usually speak english very well,
so it will be hard to practice.
When you try to speak dutch with people,
they'll probably answer you in english,
but you can solve that problem by taking
some lessons or doing a language
exchange and practicing on your own
until you reach a fairly good level and
have a fairly good base.
Then after that,
you can speak to people in dutch without
totally pissing them off.
The question of the day.
For native speakers of dutch,
how well can you understand the speakers
have regional languages that are related
to dutch languages like frisian or low
saxon,
and for people who have studied dutch,
what was your experience with trying to
learn and practice dutch?
How did people respond to you?
Did they answer you in english?
What was the best way for you to learn
and practice dutch?
Leave your answers and your comments
down below.
Be sure to follow lang,
focus on twitter,
on facebook and on instagram,
and thanks again to all of my patrion
supporters for your wonderful
contributions every month.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.